FEMALE SPEAKER: Dr. David Solit.
I have to start with
a personal note.
He's part of my family.
And so I've always been
excited about David
and who he is as a person,
and I'm excited about his work
as well.
He's my nephew.
But more importantly
than that, he's
the director at the Kravis
Center for Molecular Oncology
at the Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center in New York City.
He's both a researcher
and clinician,
and works on all
areas of cancer.
And today he's going to talk
about an aspect of his research
that I find fascinating
when I understand it.
And so thank you so much David,
for coming and talking to us.
DAVID B. SOLIT: Thanks for
the invitation to present.
I am out here this weekend
riding in a cancer fundraiser
called Cycle for Survival.
So since I was in town, I
guess I had the opportunity
to create this
Google YouTube stream
and speak to you guys
today about what we've
been doing at Sloan Kettering.
So really what I want to
talk to you about today
is how we're trying to use
a big data computational
approach to identify
new drug targets,
and how we're actually
studying what we
call extraordinary responders.
These are patients who
really beat the odds.
These are people who have a
cancer that most patients die
of, and oftentimes very quickly.
But these are those
rare individuals
who overcame those odds and
are alive many years later.
And what we try to do is analyze
tumors from those patients
so that we can learn
lessons from that
and hopefully identify
new drug targets
that we can apply in the
broader population of patients.
So I've been at Sloan
Kettering now it's 18 years.
And I run both the research lab.
I also see patients as
a medical oncologist.
And really what the focus
of my lab's efforts is
is to really try to
identify these drug targets.
And so we try to accelerate
this target discovery.
And it's a pretty simple
paradigm that we follow.
It's really up here on
this first slide here.
We try to define targets.
And I'm going to spend
a few minutes talking
about what these targets
are and how we find them.
We then, in the
laboratory, try to identify
a drug that selectively
will inhibit
that altered target that's
making the cancer cell grow
or something downstream
from that drug target
that'll kill the cancer cell.
And then what is a
major challenge--
and I'll talk to you about
that for the second part
of the talk-- is
how do we identify
the individual patients who
have an alteration in their drug
target so that we can give
them a particular drug?
And that's really
what we try to do.
So what are these targets?
There's really two main ways
to identify these targets.
One's called a genotype
to phenotype approach.
And then I'll mention to you the
opposite, which is a phenotype
to genotype approach.
So the genotype to phenotype
approach-- or G to P--
is where we take a large
group of tumor samples
and then we retrospectively do
molecular profiling on them.
And this is usually what's
called next-gen sequencing
at this point.
There are three
billion base pairs
of DNA within the human genome.
And what we try
to do is sequence
that genome in these
individual tumors
and then use a
statistical approach
to find things that are commonly
altered in multiple patients
with the same cancer.
So if you see the same
mutation again and again
in a particular
cancer type, that
gives you a statistical clue
that that mutation maybe
is important for the
growth of that cancer.
And so this was really the paper
that really changed my career.
I was what was called a
postdoctoral fellow working
in the laboratory
of someone else.
I hadn't gotten
my own laboratory
when this paper came
out in a journal called
"Nature," which is
one of the big biology
journals in the field.
And it was a very simple
experiment that they did.
What they did is they took
1,000 cancer samples--
some tumors, some cell
lines that were tumors
that they now had
growing on plastic--
and they sequenced a
common pathway that's
activated in cancer called
the MAP kinase pathway.
And then what they
were looking for
was genes that hadn't been known
to be mutated that were mutated
in these tumors commonly.
And so when they
sequenced that pathway,
they found this
gene called BRAF.
And this was interesting
because at the time,
nobody had studied BRAF.
There's actually three
different types of RAF proteins.
There's ARAF, there's
BRAF, there's CRAF.
CRAF is also called
RAF1, and it's the one
that everyone had been
biologically focusing on.
And it turned out that people
were really missing the boat.
And this non-biased approach,
by just sequencing 1,000 tumors,
identified that BRAF mutations
were found in about 80
of those, so in about
8% of all those tumors.
And that was about
50% of melanomas,
but also scattered
throughout other tumor types.
What was notable about
these BRAF mutations
is that about 95% of them
were the exact same change
in the DNA.
So it was a substitution
of one amino nucleotide
for another nucleotide,
which causes
a single base pair amino
acid change in this protein.
And when you do that, you
actually activate that protein
constitutively.
So that's why these
people get cancer.
They have an abnormal protein
that's always turned on.
And when you have a
situation like that,
if you can develop an inhibitor
of that activated enzyme,
you oftentimes have
a new cancer drug.
And that's what we tested
in the lab after that.
So what we did is we took a
panel of cancer cell lines.
We looked to see which ones had
BRAF mutations, which ones had
a mutation upstream called
RAS that had already
been discovered a
few years prior,
and then which
ones had activation
of this, what's called
MAP kinase pathway,
but due to upstream activation.
And what we found
in the laboratory
was that these tumors
that had BRAF mutations
were selectively
dependant upon BRAF.
Because if you have a mutation,
and the cancer cell is not
dependant upon that mutation,
then developing a drug
that targets that
mutation's probably not
going to have too much
of a dramatic effect.
If you actually look
at the chronology here,
this experiment
was done in 2002.
We did this biologic
experiment in 2006.
And then it took
about til 2010 til
we had a good drug that we
could actually test in patients.
And this is just some early
data from the phase one trial.
That's the first in human study
of a drug that selectively
inhibits RAF.
And this is a patient with
very advanced melanoma.
All of these dark dots here
on this PET scan are cancer.
And you can see 15
days later, after being
on this selective
inhibitor of BRAF,
this patient's had a complete
response on our PET scan.
And this is a CAT scan
showing regression
of those tumors in
this patient's lung.
And ultimately in
a randomized study,
we were able to
show that this drug,
if you give it to
patients with melanoma who
have this BRAF mutation, that
those patients live longer.
And actually we were able
to show in the laboratory
that if you give this
same drug to cells
that lack the BRAF mutation,
those cells actually
grow faster.
So it really becomes
critical that
for each individual patient,
before we treat them,
we know whether they
have the BRAF mutation
or whether they don't
have the BRAF mutation.
Because if we give them
the BRAF inhibitor,
they're likely to benefit if
they have a BRAF mutation.
If we give them
the BRAF inhibitor
and they're BRAF
wild type tumor,
their tumor may
actually grow faster
and they may die quicker.
So really what the challenge has
become somewhat in our cancer
population is how
do we figure out
who's got what mutations
within their tumor?
Because again,
these mutations can
be scattered over this
entire human genome, which
makes up about three billion
different base pairs.
So that's one way to
approach this problem.
That way is really a
statistical approach.
It takes large numbers.
It takes a large consortium.
And there's an effort called
the Tumor Cancer Genome
Atlas that's trying to do
that across the country.
And that's one way to do it.
And we actually came up
with the opposite idea.
Can we actually take patients
who were on cancer drugs
and they responded incredibly
well to those cancer drugs--
most patients didn't, or maybe
nobody else didn't-- and can we
find out what was the mutation
that made them respond?
Because if we could
figure that out,
we already have a good
drug because it worked
in that individual already.
And if we could just find
other patients just like them,
we have a drug ready
for those individuals.
So could we expand
out the number
of patients who would benefit?
And the real inspiration
for this work
was this clinical trial that
we ran in Sloan Kettering
a few years ago.
So this was a trial
we ran back in 2008.
We did this trial in
patients with bladder cancer.
And like every other
bladder cancer trial
we've done over the
past 20 to 30 years,
this was a negative study.
So we enrolled 45 patients
on to this clinical trial.
Only two of those
patients responded.
And based upon that result,
statistically one would say OK,
this drug which we
were testing here
called Everolimus-- it's made
by a company called Novartis--
that this drug doesn't work in
patients with bladder cancer.
So let's maybe move
on to the next idea.
But despite the fact that
in the entire population
it wasn't impressive,
this patient
here-- and I'm showing
her CAT scans-- really
jumped out at us.
And so just to give you
her history briefly,
her history actually
begins off the slide here.
In the summer of
2009, she presented
with a bladder cancer
that had already
spread to her lymph nodes.
So it was already what
we call metastatic.
And what we try to do in
these patients is we give them
chemotherapy, we try to
shrink the tumor down,
we try to cut
everything out, and then
in a percentage of those
patients we cure the cancer.
But unfortunately,
by the fall of 2009,
her cancer had come back, it had
spread back to the lymph nodes.
And you can see here in January
2010, she had this CAT scan.
And really this area here that
the red arrows are pointing at,
that's her tumor.
And that spread out
through her abdomen.
And actually in this situation,
a patient with bladder cancer
who's had a prior
line of chemotherapy,
we have no standard of care.
And the average survival
of these patients
is only nine months.
And so we really
encourage these patients
to go on clinical trials.
And for no particular
reason other than it
was an open clinical trial at
Sloan Kettering at the time,
this woman enrolled on
the Everolimus study.
And despite the fact that this
drug really didn't work well
in anybody else,
by April 2010 she
had achieved a near
complete response.
By July 2010, a
What I mean by that is that
all the tumors had completely
resolved.
If you look at July 2011,
still in a complete response.
'12, '13, '14.
She was actually just back in
our clinic a few weeks ago.
And she's now at her
five year anniversary
being on this compound without
any evidence of disease,
despite the fact
that this again,
in the overall population,
was a negative study.
In fact, every other
patient on this study
has died of their disease.
She's the only one who's alive.
And not only is she alive, her
cancer's completely gone away.
So again, what makes her unique?
So at the time, back in
2008, 2009, the technology
that we had available really
allowed us to look at one gene
at a time for mutations.
And that was pretty limiting.
We could have a hypothesis
based upon the biology
around Everolimus that
maybe this gene or that gene
was important for this response.
So we did that type of approach.
We looked at a few genes
and a candidate approach.
Couldn't find what really was
unique about this patient.
But what happened along the way
is that technology improved.
And this was both what we
call sequencing technology
and then also just the
computational power,
our ability to analyze this
data expanded to the point
where we could now
do whole genomes.
And so actually, the first
whole genome sequence
of a normal cell
was not completed
until about the year 2000.
The first cancer genomes were
only about five years ago.
And those first
cancer genomes were
costing on an average hundreds
of millions of dollars
to complete in their entirety.
The technology eventually
progressed to the point where,
for just a small amount
of money at the time,
for this paired
genome for sequencing
both their tumor and their
normal cost about $20,000.
That's already down
to about $2,000
today, just a few years later.
But again, by being able to
sequence her whole genome
and being able to
analyze all that data,
we're able to figure out every
single place in her tumor
genome where there's
a mutation and it's
different than
her normal genome.
And if you do that
analysis, you come up
with 17,000 mutations
that are in her tumor that
are not in her normal.
And you say well, how
are you going to sort
through 17,000 data points?
But it's a real
testament to how much
we've learned about the
biology of these genes
over the past several
decades that we're
able to very quickly
bioinformatically map
every single one of
these 17,000 mutations
to what we call the
reference genome.
We can ask, which
of these mutations
are present in a coding
region of a gene?
Which of these
mutations would be
predicted, based
upon an algorithm,
to change the protein function?
And which of these genes that
change a protein function when
they have a mutation would
be predicted to be associated
with Everolimus response?
And when you do
that, you can take
all 17,000 of these mutations
and actually boil it down
to just two-- one called TSE1
and the other called NF2.
And the reason these
were so interesting
is that when you mutated
both TSE1 and TSE2,
you activated a
protein TORC-1, which
is the direct target
of Everolimus.
So if you look at this
patient in retrospect,
she was the perfect
patient to get this drug.
We simply didn't know it
going into the clinical trial,
because we didn't
know what genes
were mutated in her tumor.
Actually, at about the
time-- I'll just go back--
that we were getting
these results back,
there was actually
a clinical trial
published that this same
drug Everolimus works
in patients who have a condition
called tuberous sclerosis.
This is an inherited disease
where patients get cancer
at a very young age due
to germ line mutations
in the same gene, TSE1.
And so these are people who
are born with already one
defective copy of this gene.
If they lose the other
copy in a normal cell,
they then get tumors.
And because normally you have
to lose both copies of a gene,
if it's a tumor
suppressor, to get a tumor,
these people are very
susceptible to getting cancer
and they get cancer
at a very young age.
So we've now taken this
extraordinary responder
paradigm and we've
applied it to other cases.
And I just want to mention
one other quickly here today.
This is a second patient who
was a young woman in her 40s.
She presented with a
mass in her abdomen.
It was a localized tumor, so
the surgeons opened her up.
They went ahead and
cut out this tumor.
And if you look at this
tumor under the microscope,
this patient has what's
called a small cell
cancer of the urothelial tract.
And this type of tumor has a
particularly grim prognosis.
So if you look at our series
of this type of cancer
at Sloan Kettering
over the past 10 years,
essentially all patients
with this disease
die of their disease.
And so given that really grim
prognosis, the doctors who
were treating her went
ahead and gave her
some chemotherapy,
the [INAUDIBLE],
even though she didn't
have any cancer.
And we call this
adjuvant therapy.
It's the type of
chemotherapy you
give try to prevent the
cancer from coming back.
We do this very commonly in
breast cancer and in colon
cancer.
But unfortunately, despite
getting this chemotherapy,
just a few months later,
her cancer came back.
It had now metastasized
to the kidney.
She now had metastases,
and so spread to the lymph
nodes in the abdomen.
And so what they went ahead
and did is they actually went,
took her back to surgery.
They cut all this
cancer out again.
Usually that doesn't work,
but they were really desperate
and had really no other options.
And unfortunately, just a
few months later, the cancer
had come back again
in the abdomen
and had now spread to the bone.
And so this was really
not a good story.
This is one that probably
was not going to end well.
And so what we recommended
is that we just
don't have good standard
treatments for you.
We referred her for
a clinical trial,
and they referred her to
what's called a phase one
clinical trial.
This is really the first
[? in-man ?] human study where
we're not even sure what's
the side effect of the drugs,
what's the right dose to give.
And so she ultimately again,
for no particular reason
other than it was an
open study at the time,
was enrolled on the study of a
chemotherapy called Irinotecan,
and a second drug
called AZD7762,
which is an inhibitor of
a kinase-- or an enzyme,
you could say--
within the cell that's
important for DNA
repair and checkpoint
to allow for DNA repair.
And the hypothesis
with this trial
was that the cancer cells would
be more susceptible to DNA
damage from the chemotherapy.
This kinase inhibitor would
prevent this DNA repair
from happening in the
cancer cells selectively,
and that would thus enhance the
effects of the chemotherapy.
And it was a good idea.
There was some evidence
in the laboratory
that this could work.
But unfortunately, they
saw a lot of side effects
with this combination.
And they really weren't
seeing a lot of activities.
So midway through treatment
on this clinical trial,
the company AstraZeneca
actually discontinued
the entire program.
So they stopped the
development of this AZD7762.
And that was despite the fact
that this patient had actually
achieved a complete response.
So all her cancer had gone away.
But she was really
the only one where
we saw that type of response.
And so given the fact that they
had discontinued the program,
she had to stop taking the drug.
They continued the chemotherapy
for a few more months,
eventually had to stop
that to give her a break.
They were expecting the cancer
would come right back once they
stopped the treatment.
And that was about
four years ago.
Her cancer's never
come back and she's now
probably cured of her cancer.
So again, this is a woman
who was cured of a cancer
that everybody dies
of on a drug that
was so disappointing
in the clinic
that the company discontinued it
during the first clinical trial
that was being done.
So we went ahead and we
sequenced this woman's
entire tumor genome.
And this is called
a Circos plot.
It's a way for us just
to represent graphically
the complexity of
her tumor genome.
We just take the chromosomes,
we line them up in a circle.
These line show translocations,
so a breakage of one chromosome
where it's recombined
into another.
This inner circle shows copy
number alterations, so gains
or losses of particular genes.
And then this woman actually
had 19,000 somatic mutations.
These are alterations
that are in the tumor that
are not present in the normal.
So again, how do we sort
through all this information?
Just to give you some
hints of how we do that.
One thing we do is we can
actually align these genes
to the homologues of these
genes in other species.
So we can take particular genes
that are mutated informatically
and align them to the
same gene in a mouse,
or the same gene in
a Drosophila fly,
or the same gene in a yeast,
or the same gene in a bacteria.
And when you have areas
where the gene is identical
in a human, in a mouse,
in a dog, in a Drosophila,
in a yeast, in a bacteria,
that's a part of the gene
that you simply can't mutate
without altering its function.
So we can prioritize
that mutations
in that part of
the genome are more
likely to be functional or
disruptive of the protein's
function.
And so when you go ahead and
do that, again we go back
and we take the 19,000
genes, we match them
up to the coding regions.
We actually narrow it down
to just a couple hundred
doing that.
And then we take those
couple hundred candidates,
we align them evolutionarily.
And when we do that, there was
a particular gene called RAD50
where there was a
single base pair
substitution in that gene where
it was in a part of the protein
called the D loop.
And that part is essentially
the same in humans, in mice,
in Drosophila, in
yeast, in bacteria.
And so that really allowed us to
prioritize this particular gene
mutation for further functional
validation versus for example,
this ATR mutation,
which was also
mutated in this
patient's tumor but was
not in a known functional
area of the protein
and was not in an area of
evolutionary conservation.
We can also take these
different genes that
are mutated and based upon
crystal structures of proteins
that have been made, we can
actually model off the crystal
structure where the
mutation is in the protein
and what this specific
amino acid substitution is
potentially going to do to the
interaction of that protein
with other proteins.
And so this is just
showing in this patient who
had this unbelievable
curative response, that this
is a protein complex of actually
three different proteins called
the MRE complex.
And this mutation in
RAD50 would actually
be predicted to be on the
interface between RAD50
and another protein called
MRE11, would actually
disrupt binding of
these two proteins,
and would actually
disrupt the function.
So based upon again, this
evolutionary conservation
and this crystal
structure modeling,
we're able to take
these 19,000 mutations
and really focus on
this one mutation that
seems most interesting.
But even there, it's really
a computer prediction.
It's a guess.
And we still need to
go back to the lab
to do functional
studies to prove
that that hypothesis
makes a lot of sense.
So what we did in this patient,
to make a long story short,
is we took advantage of this
evolutionary conservation
within this protein
to actually do
a cross species validation of
this mutation in a yeast model.
So because the yeast
protein for this pathway
is identical in
humans and in yeast,
we can knock this
mutation into yeast
and see if it disrupts
the protein function
and whether it
would maybe explain
this woman's
incredible sensitivity
to the chemotherapy.
And so that's really
this experiment here.
And what we're showing
in this experiment is
if you knock in this
RAD50 mutation into yeast-
and actually yeast just
have one copy of the genome,
these are haploid yeast--
you get some sensitization
to the chemotherapy here.
But if you actually knock in
this RAD50 mutation and also
knock out the
check one pathway--
and so MEC1 is the
homologue of ATR,
which activates
upstream check one--
you get what's called
a synthetically lethal
interaction.
So you see a killing
of these cells
when you have both the RAD50
mutation and knockout check
one when you give the
chemotherapy that you don't see
when you give the
chemotherapy to cells
that don't have this
particular mutation profile.
So again, like the first
patient I talked to you about,
this patient was
the perfect patient
for this combination of drugs.
We simply didn't know it
going into the clinical trial.
But one could now hypothesize
that if we knew the mutation
status of all of
these patients going
into these clinical trials, we
could do these clinical trials
more effectively, hopefully
get them done quicker,
and hopefully see better
results going forward.
So this is really the paradigm
of this extraordinary responder
initiative that's now gone
nationwide through the National
Cancer Institute.
We take a clinical trial
which was disappointing,
but for which there were
some patients who seemed
to benefit from the treatment.
We take tumors from
those patients.
We do some sort of
genetic analysis
to figure out potentially what
made those patients unique.
It's not showing up
on the slide here,
but we always go back
to the laboratory
to do functional
validation of that biology.
And then what we need
is we need an assay,
we need a test that will
allow us to perspectively
now look for those particular
mutations in everybody.
So we know who has
which mutations
so that we can do an iterative
clinical trial where we just
enroll patients
with that mutation
onto this drug to ask how
many of them are going to have
similar type of responses.
So how are we going
to find the patients?
What is the assay
that we're going to do
to actually do this analysis?
And so this is what we're
doing at Sloan Kettering.
We run an assay called
MSK-IMPACT-- IMPACT standing
for Integrated Mutation
Profiling of Actionable Cancer
Targets.
And so this is an
assay of 341 genes.
And I took out the slide.
And so what we know
about cancer is
that genes are not
necessarily distributed
in terms of the
important mutations all
the way throughout the genome.
That there's certain parts
of the genome, certain cancer
genes, that are more likely
to be important than others.
And so what we can do
to try to save costs,
to save money so that we
can sequence more patients
and get more from our sequencing
resource, what we can do
is we can take DNA from multiple
patients, we can chop it up,
we can then attach a DNA barcode
to each of those individual DNA
molecules, and then mix all
those DNA molecules together
in the same reaction.
And then we can use
those barcode DNAs
in a very powerful
computer at the end
to actually figure out
which DNA molecule came
from which patient.
And so by mixing all these
in the same reaction,
that allows us to save money.
And I hope you've
got a plug. [LAUGHS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's there.
I don't know why it's not.
Keep talking.
DAVID B. SOLIT: OK.
The other way we
save money is we
can actually pull down
the parts of the genome
that we're most interested in.
So we develop dates.
We develop DNA dates that
will go and hybridize
with the parts of the genome
where the cancer mutations are
most likely to be found.
And that again allows us to
save money on the sequencing
resource in the future.
And so we've
developed this assay.
It's a custom assay.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Question.
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVID B. SOLIT: So this is
called next-gen sequencing,
and it's really a
digital platform.
So we sequence each individual
DNA molecule separately.
And what we try to do is try
to sequence each of these DNA
molecules 500 or 1,000 times.
And the reason that
we need to do that
is because the normal DNA is
mixed in with the tumor DNA.
We can't usually get
a pure population
of just cancer cells.
And so if the tumor that we cut
out from the patient and then
smushed up and
extract the DNA out
of it, if that's 70% normal
cells and 30% tumor cells,
we need to get
better sensitivity
for finding the mutations.
We want to have
very deep coverage.
And that means sequencing
that same part of the genome
again and again and
again to make sure we
don't miss the mutation.
Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID B. SOLIT: So we've
created this initiative
at Sloan Kettering.
And really the initiative
is pretty simple.
What we're trying
to do here is we're
trying to sequence
every single patient
with advanced metastatic
cancer at Sloan Kettering using
this assay.
And so we see about
45,000 unique patients
with cancer at Sloan
Kettering every single year.
About 75% of these
patients are cured.
About a quarter of them
develop recurrent disease
and are thus at highest risk
of dying of their cancer
and thus the most in
need for novel therapies.
And so we've got about
10,000 to 12,000 patients
like that at Sloan
Kettering every year.
And so we are going
to attempt, and we've
begun this effort just
over the past year,
use this assay to sequence every
single one of those patients.
We actually sequence
both the tumor
and we also sequence
the normal DNA.
And by sequencing the normal
DNA in all these genes,
there's actually the potential
to identify a mutation that's
in the normal cells
that was actually
the reason that the patient got
the cancer in the first place.
So genes like BRCA1
or BRCA2, these
are risk factor genes that
make it more likely that you're
going to get cancer.
What's the major
hurdle to doing this?
Previously up to this
year, it was technology.
But now it's really
money, like many things.
So it's very expensive
to do the sequencing.
And that's why I was
focusing on how can we
bring the cost of the
sequencing down by mixing DNA
from multiple patients
together and just sequencing
parts of the genome?
And it's both
expensive and it's not
standard to do this type
of testing in most patients
with cancer.
So we can only bill
insurance companies
to do this type of testing
in six adult tumors.
So patients with lung
cancer, colorectal, melanoma,
GIST tumors,
thyroid, and patients
with diffuse gliomas,
which are brain cancers.
So people with breast cancer,
folks with prostate cancer,
endometrial cancer, ovarian
cancer, bladder cancer, these
are not tumors that we can
get any sort of insurance
or Medicare reimbursement
for doing the sequencing.
So to be able to do this
sequencing, we need to go out
and we need to raise funds.
And I'm actually
here this weekend
riding with Cycle for
Survival to raise funds
to do this type of sequencing.
And so our plan is to
try to do this as a
what we call a research
non billable test,
try to sequence everyone,
and then use this information
to try to drive patients to
the most appropriate treatment.
We've also made a decision
at Sloan Kettering
that we're going to make
the data that we generate
using this assay available
to everyone at the Center
in real time.
So what we've done is we've
created this web-based portal
and database called the
cBioPortal for Cancer Genomics.
And there's both
a private version
of this portal and a public
version that you can access.
But this is really almost cancer
bioinformatics for dummies.
It really is a
way for biologists
who don't have a
computational degree, maybe
knowledge of how to do
a Unix command prompt
or other training, to be
able to browse this data.
So if you're a clinician and
you're not an informatician,
or you're a biologist
and just don't
have a bioinformatics
degree, this type of portal
lets you figure out
very quickly where
mutation's found in particular
cancer types, what's
the co-mutation
pattern, how often
are those mutations found.
And this data's now available
to everyone at Sloan Kettering.
And this is the summary
page of that portal.
And I just blew it up here
so that you can see it.
It lists how many of each
cancer that we've done.
441 patients with breast
cancer, 393 with lung cancer,
222 with colorectal,
all down the line.
And we're not just
doing common cancers.
We're also doing
very rare cancers.
We've done one patient for
example with a Wilms' tumor.
This is a very rare
pediatric cancer.
We've done a couple patients
who have Fallopian tube cancers,
another very rare cancer.
And so we're doing both common
cancers and rare tumor types.
There's a patient centered
view for these tumors.
And you can see this
is a patient who
had a colorectal cancer which
had one of these BRAF mutations
that we now have a drug
against that I mentioned
to you a little bit earlier.
But the patient also has a
number of other mutations
that are picked up by the assay.
And so this type
of sequencing may
allow us to understand
maybe why some patients
with BRAF reputations who
get the BRAF inhibitor
do better than others.
So some patients may
have a co-mutation
that makes their tumor
less dependent upon BRAF
and thus less sensitive
to that inhibitor.
We've also created
a database which
is out there to actually educate
the clinicians as to what
this information means.
So many of the oncologists who
treat these patients really
just never got the
education in cancer genetics
to even understand what we're
talking about when we talk
about all these gene mutations.
And so there's 20,000 plus
genes in the human genome.
I don't know off
the top of my head
the four digit code for
every single one of those
and what that gene does.
And so we almost
need a computer tool
to be able to, when
this data comes back,
be able to give us data.
This gene has this
function and when
you have this particular
mutation in the gene, that's
a functional mutation
and causes sensitivity
to a particular drug.
So this database is something
that's a work in progress.
But something that actually
doesn't exist publicly
is something we're
actually hoping
maybe we can get together with
other major cancer centers
and do a Wikipedia type of
model where everybody puts
in their specific
knowledge expertise
and eventually you
then crowd source
this sort of important
data for all 20,000
plus genes in the genome.
But currently, we
have this data just
for the genes that
we have in our assay.
And even there,
it's only partial.
So it's a real work in
progress, and a real problem.
Because when this data comes
back, most oncologists again,
they don't know what these
particular mutations mean
and what they do.
So again, this is--
yeah, go ahead.
So if we actually go back
one slide here before this
comes up.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID B. SOLIT: Yeah.
Yeah.
OK, so can we
compare our database
to 1000 Genomes or the
Sanger database and others?
And cBioPortal has become a
public database in some ways.
So all the Tumor Cancer Genome
Atlas that's publicly available
is now searchable
in the cBioPortal.
Other published
databases are now
brought into the cBioPortal.
And so this has
actually become, I
think, the primary
tool for most people
who are not cancer
bioinformaticians to really
sort through the data.
But you know, the problem
is is that not everyone even
makes their data publicly
available in a way
that we can bring it
in to these databases.
So just to give you
one example, there's
a company that does germ line
testing for BRCA called Myriad.
And they've probably tested
close to 200,000 plus patients
with breast and ovarian
cancer for these germ line
alterations.
But they consider that
data to be proprietary.
They don't release it, and
so we don't have that data.
So it really is
going to be important
that anything public gets
into these type of databases.
And it's not something that
a cancer center necessarily
was in the best position to do.
I mean, that's
not our expertise.
And so we've created this
initiative at Sloan Kettering.
But I'll tell you,
we'd love to reach out
to people who have better
experience putting together
these type of databases to
make these tools even better.
So I think that
remains a problem.
There's a lot of
proprietary data out there,
but I think there's enough
in the public domain
that if you really consolidated
it into one source,
it would be incredibly valuable.
So again, that's how we're
going to find the mutations.
And now I just want to
talk for a few minutes
about how are we going to
do the clinical trials that
are actually going to take this
genetic information to really
test these new drugs?
And so there's
really two main ways
we can do these clinical trials.
One is called an umbrella
protocol or a master protocol.
And these protocols
are usually centered
around a particular cancer type.
So this would be a master
protocol for patients with lung
cancer, as an example.
And so what we do here is
we sequence all the patients
with lung cancer, maybe
at multiple institutions.
And then depending upon
what mutation they have,
we put them on different
drugs based upon that.
And many of the doctors
like this approach,
because as I mentioned
earlier, it's
very hard to find the funds
to sequence the patients.
And so if you have a
clinical trial like this,
you can ask the drug companies
maybe that make these drugs--
the EGFR inhibitor, the BRAF
inhibitor, the MAC inhibitor--
to maybe pay for the sequencing.
So this is one way
that we try to do this.
And there are some
master protocols open
for patients with lung cancer
and some other tumor types.
There's a few problems
with this approach though.
One is that oftentimes
it's not the same drug
company that makes each drug.
And so drug company one might
make the EGFR inhibitor,
drug company two may
make the BRAF inhibitor,
and so on and so forth.
So sometimes you can spend
a year or two negotiating
with different drug
companies to get
the different drugs into this
one giganto clinical trial.
And by the time you've
actually secured the drugs
and opened the trial, maybe
one or two of these drugs
have already failed
in another context
and they're not really the best
in class drug that's available.
So that's one downside.
The other downside
I'm going to focus on
is that oftentimes these
are small clinical trials.
And maybe you're sequencing
in this clinical trial
200 patients.
And if you've got a
mutation in the population
that you're studying
that's only 1% or 2% or 3%
of the population,
you're not going
to get enough patients
on to this clinical trial
with that particular
mutation to really answer
the primary question, which
is if you have this mutation,
do you respond to this specific
inhibitor of that drug?
So that's one approach.
But if you could find
the right patient ,
you can sometimes see
these incredible effects.
This is a patient
with lung cancer.
And actually in lung
cancer, these BRAF mutations
I mentioned to you earlier only
make up about 1% to maybe 2%
of the population.
But if you can find that rare
patient who has a BRAF mutation
and give them the
same drug that works
in melanoma-- in this
case, [INAUDIBLE],
which is a selective
inhibitor of RAF--
you can see these type
of incredible effects.
This is a patient who's been
on this drug for over two years
with a disease that most
patients progress very quickly
and die within a year or two.
So again, if you can
match the right patient
on to the right drug by some
mechanism, this can work.
But for these rare mutations,
this type of master protocol
design is really inefficient.
So what we've tried to do
is create a different type
of trial design that works for
mutations where the mutation is
found in a lot of
different cancers,
but is not common
in any of them.
And so an example
of that is a gene
called ERBB2, which is mutated
in pretty much every different
cancer.
But usually about
1% or 2% or 3%.
So there's a lot
of these mutations.
If you add them up,
there's probably
10,000 patients in
this country a year
who have a ERBB2 mutant tumor.
But in most cancers, like
breast cancer, it's only 2%
of the population.
So if you wanted
to just test for it
and then enroll a
breast cancer trial,
you'd have to test
100 patients to find
two who have the mutation.
And that's a very
inefficient way to do that.
So what we've decided
to do is we've
created this new type of trial
that we call a basket trial.
And what a basket
trial is it's a trial
that's focused around a specific
gene or mutation and not
around a particular tumor.
So we can take any patient.
It doesn't matter what
kind of cancer you have,
as long as you have the
mutation we're interested in.
And for this study of a
drug called Neratinib,
we're looking for patients
with a ERBB2 mutation.
And it doesn't matter if you
have a bladder cancer or colon
cancer, an endometrial,
gastric, ovarian, breast.
It doesn't matter.
If you have a ERBB2 mutation,
you can go on to the study.
We always have another
arm for these studies
as well, because maybe
there's some other rare cancer
type that we didn't even
know had ERBB2 mutations.
But we find one, we want
to give the opportunity
to test whether that patient's
going to respond to the drug.
And we've seen some incredible
responses with this approach.
So this is a patient who has
one of these ERBB2 mutations.
And we generally don't test
for these mutations in breast
cancer, which is what she has.
And this is a woman who'd
been through many lines
of chemotherapy,
none of which were
working because they weren't
targeting the right mutation.
And you can see
from her PET scan,
she had this incredibly
high burden of disease.
All of these are actually
metastasis from her cancer.
This is her brain,
this is her bladder.
Some of this is her
heart, but most of these
are all mutations.
And actually see less
uptake in the heart
because so much of the PET
tracer here-- the glucose
that we inject, the
radioactive glucose tracer--
is going up in the tumor.
And so she was started on
this drug on this basket study
in July of 2004.
Within two months, she's
had a complete response.
But the key issue here is
not that it's surprising
that this ERBB2 inhibitor,
which is what Neratinib is,
would work in this
ERBB2 mutant patient.
The real problem is that
almost all patients who
have this mutation-- this V77L
missense mutation in ERBB2--
are unaware that they
have this mutation
because we don't test
for this mutation.
So since nobody's testing for
it, we can't find the patients.
We can't put them on
the trial and we can't
prove that the drug works.
So it's really a chicken
and the egg problem.
How do you prove the drug
works without knowing
who has the mutation?
How can you actually justify
doing the testing unless you
know that the drug works?
Because otherwise,
the insurance company
won't pay for the testing.
And so to try to break this
chicken and the egg cycle,
we've just made this
commitment that we
are going to test everyone using
institutional funds until we
can essentially enroll enough
patients onto these trials
to prove that these
drugs work or don't work.
It's a little more complicated
than I'm making it out to be.
There are multiple different
ERBB2 mutations in cancer.
They may all respond a little
bit differently to the drug.
And so what we do with the
basket study, for example,
is we can take this
breast cancer arm.
We can initially enroll all the
patients with ERBB2 mutations.
Since we've already
seen a positive result
on the overall arm, we
can then do sub-baskets
where we enroll a
cohort of patients
that have this S310 mutation,
a cohort of patients
with an L755 mutation, a cohort
with V77L on down the line.
And again, we always
have another arm
for these rare
mutations to give access
to the drug to these patients.
And the question is, can we
eventually get to a point
where we've got a rare
enough mutation disease
combination where almost
everybody's responding
that the FDA would simply allow
us to change standard of care
at that point?
So typically, the FDA has
required us, for cancer drugs,
to do randomized studies.
Where one half of the
patients or so get the drug,
the other half get a placebo
or an older standard drug
that doesn't work very well.
And the question
is, can we avoid
those type of randomized studies
by very carefully selecting
the patients so that the benefit
is so high on a small study
that it compels the community
to just change standard of care?
Because you could imagine if we
were seeing this type of result
in 80% or 90% percent
of the patients
with this mutation
in breast cancer,
a patient with that exact
mutation in breast cancer
doesn't want to go on a placebo.
And it might sound ridiculous to
even consider that possibility.
But the [INAUDIBLE] study that
I told you about earlier was
that exact situation.
And despite that,
we actually had
to do a placebo controlled
study by the FDA.
In that case, there were enough
patients to do that trial.
I don't even think there's
enough patients in the country
to do a placebo controlled study
of just V77L ERBB2 mutations
with Neratinib.
So hopefully, the regulators
will accept this and change
the way we do things.
Question?
So I guess the
question was are we
potentially missing important
mutations or other alterations
by just sequencing the 410
genes that our current assay is
looking at?
And the answer is
absolutely correct.
But my initial answer that
question would be this
is an example of not
letting the perfect be
the enemy of the good.
So since we can't do
whole genome sequencing
on every single
patient, that shouldn't
prevent us to do 410 genes
on every single patient.
So we're doing what we're
feasibly able to do right now.
But the expectation is
that this sequencing
is going to become
cheaper over time,
and the computational
power to do the analysis
gets cheaper and
quicker over time.
And everybody I'm
sure in this room
knows of Moore's Law,
which is the rate
at which computational power
becomes more powerful and less
expensive.
The rate at which sequencing
is becoming more powerful
is actually much
dramatically faster
than what you see with Moore's
Law with semiconductors.
So we're seeing this
incredibly fast drop
in the cost of sequencing.
And there's companies
like Illumina
and others that are
making these machines that
are driving this improvement.
And it's probably
a few years away
from a point where we will
be getting that whole genome
sequence on every patient.
We just feasibly
can't do it now.
But there are
probably some patients
who are going out and having
their whole genome sequenced.
There might be a few
patients of means that can
convince somebody to do that.
My lab does it in this
retrospective approach
for these rare,
extraordinary responders.
But each one of those not only
costs the lab tens of thousands
of dollars to do,
but it takes actually
a team of informaticians
weeks to do the analysis.
So we need the cost
of the sequencing
to come down and
then what we need
is better algorithmic
approaches for the analysis
so that you can take these
billions of data points
and be able to analyze
them much more quickly.
And one way to do
that is to have
this central database
of all known variant
changes that you're
able to reference.
And so the fact
that we've only done
a small number of
whole genomes so far
make it difficult for us
to know whether something
found in a particular
genome is important.
Because the more you
do, the more often you
see these patterns
that allow you to know
that something is real or not.
But it's a great question.
So what are the advantages
of this basket approach?
I'm a clinician, but I'm also a
cancer biologist, a geneticist.
What this allows
us to do is really
test that defined
biologic hypothesis.
Does a ERBB2 inhibitor work in
patients with a ERBB2 mutation?
How often does it work?
If it works in some
patients and not others,
we can collect tumors
from all those patients,
we can maybe do whole
genome sequencing
in that whole cohort,
and figure out
what are the co-mutations that
determine that heterogeneity
within even that small class.
We're also doing on
this trial what's
called a co-clinical trial,
where we enroll patients not
just with known
activating mutations
but also patients who have novel
mutations that have never been
biologically characterized.
And what we do is while
those patients are
on the clinical
trial, we biologically
characterize those
mutations in the laboratory.
And we may find that
for some of them,
they're not
functional mutations.
So if I go back to this
slide of ERBB2 mutations,
these hot spots have now all
been biologically validated
and are real.
As we get more and
more sequencing data,
some of these rare mutations
will become hot spots.
But some of these are just what
we call passenger mutations--
the random changes in the
DNA due to the toxin that
induced the DNA damage.
And they're not
driving the cancer.
And so we don't have
that knowledge for all
of these mutations so far.
We just have it for
the most common.
But as patients come
on to the study,
we study individual mutations
that have not already
been validated.
What are the challenges
with the approach?
The primary criticism we
get from drug companies,
clinicians,
regulators, is that we
fail to identify patients
who could respond
but they don't have the
bio-marker we're testing.
So in the case of ERBB2,
you don't necessarily
have to have a ERBB2 mutation
to benefit from Neratinib.
We actually know that's true.
Maybe you can have an activated
receptor from a ligand
that's binding.
So while that's true, it's
not the point of the study,
and we can always study those
things in later studies.
I call it the sad fact,
and that's in academia,
it's sometimes difficult to
get the lung doctors to work
with the colon doctors to get
them to work with the bladder
doctors.
They're actually not used to
doing clinical trials that way.
So the way they train, the
way they practice over decades
is you just do
breast cancer trials,
and they're separate than
doing lung cancer trials,
and they're separate
than doing colon trials.
And the concept of doing a
trial where any type of cancer
can be in that trial
is something that's
foreign to the community.
But I think that's starting
to change with some
of the success we've seen.
And again, I'm just
going to mention
that the primary hurdle really
remains that identifying
the patients is a challenge.
The vast majority of patients
with cancer in this country
don't get any testing.
There's only a few institutions
doing this right now.
The scale, that number is going
to keep going up over time.
But most patients in the
community don't get this.
There are some companies that
are now specifically opening up
to do this type of testing.
One's called
Foundation Medicine.
They charge $5,800 for the
test, and generally insurance
doesn't cover.
So for most patients,
it's not really
feasible to get
this test performed.
I just have two more slides.
I just want to point out
that the testing's not just
for selection of what we call
targeted therapies, which
are drugs that inhibit a
specific mutant protein.
This was one of the
first patients of mine
that I see in the clinic
which I did this testing for.
And this was a patient
with prostate cancer
who did very poorly with
all the standard treatments.
And so we went ahead and
we biopsied his cancer
after it had become metastatic
and had spread to other sites.
And then we did the
testing, and what
was notable about his
tumor is that he actually
had 29 mutations
identified by the assay.
And that's surprising
in prostate cancer,
because most prostate cancers
only have a few mutations.
So prostate cancer's known
for a very low mutation rate.
But this guy had a very
high mutation rate tumor.
And he actually had two
genes that were mutated.
The red bars are a little off.
One's called MLH1, the
other's called MSH2.
And these were both
truncating mutations.
And what's interesting
about these genes
is that when you get
mutations in these genes
in the normal cells, you
have a condition called
Lynch syndrome, which
leads to colorectal
cancers, endometrial cancers.
Not typically prostate
cancers, but you
get these hypermutated tumors.
And what we've learned is that
if you test immunotherapies--
these are a new class of drugs
that harness the immune system
to attack the cancer-- these
type of hypermutated tumors
are more likely to
respond than tumors
that have fewer mutations.
And that's probably
due to the fact
that these hypermutated
tumors are expressing
proteins that are seen by the
immune system as being foreign.
They're not self, they're
not the normal proteins
for that individual.
They've got a slight change
and so they're seen as foreign
and it's easier to stimulate the
immune system to attack them.
So we actually
have a basket study
where you can have
any type of cancer.
If you have one of these
type of hypermutated tumors,
this basket study
design provides access
to this type of immunotherapy.
In particular for this trial,
a drug called MEDI4736.
This is a drug that binds to
a protein called PD1, which
leads to a checkpoint
effect and a stimulation
of the immune system
to fight the cancer.
And I can say that this
patient here is actually
seeing early benefit
with this anti PD1
therapy with this
hypermutated prostate cancer.
These type of
hypermutated tumors
were not something we saw
when we did a retrospective
analysis of early tumors.
But notably, we've found
already about five or six
of these patients out
of the first 150 or so
of the prostate cancers that
we've done perspectively
at Sloan Kettering.
And it's possible that
these hypermutated tumors
are overrepresented in those
advanced metastatic patients
because these
hypermutated tumors are
less likely to respond
the standard treatment
and more likely to recur and
progress to metastatic disease.
So again, figuring
out in the end what
is driving an individual
patient's tumor,
we're hoping to use that
information to really guide
the treatment of patients.
Just one more point and
then I'll finish up.
This is this company
that I mentioned
that's been doing
this type of testing.
This was a report that was sent
to me from a patient at Johns
Hopkins asking if they could
be on this ERBB2 basket study.
And they had a
ERBB2 mutation, they
had an S310F ERBB2 mutation.
But there was this
note on the report that
was what's called subclonal.
And so what that means
is that it's likely
at least you can
infer informatically
that this mutation is not likely
present in every single cancer
cell.
And so to just show you from
our data what that means,
here's a patient
with breast cancer
who has an L755S mutation.
The allele frequency
here is the number
of reads in the tumor
that have the mutation
versus the normal reads.
And we never see this as 100%,
because typically you only
mutate one copy of the gene.
And also there's this
stromal contamination
of the normal cells,
which are obviously
normal for the mutation.
But what's notable, it's 58%
here, 20 something percent
for the other two mutations.
This is probably a
mutant where there's
two copies of the
mutation for ERBB2
and one copy for
these other two genes.
If I look at this
other patient, this
is a patient with
bladder cancer where
can see this P53 mutation's
in 57% of the reads,
the TSE1 is in 61% of the
reads, but the ERBB2 mutation's
only in 3% of the reads.
And the way you can
statistically get that
is if the ERBB2 mutation is
just in some of the cancer cells
and not in all the cancer cells.
And one could imagine that
if the mutation that we're
targeting is not in
every single cancer cell,
when we give the drug, the cells
that don't have the mutation
are probably going to quickly
grow out and become resistant.
And this type of what we
call clonality analysis
is very difficult to do when you
have limited amounts of data.
So if we only have a
small list of mutations
because we're only
sequencing a few genes,
it's very difficult to do this.
But if we do whole exome
or whole genome sequencing,
we can actually define
this clonality much better.
It still takes a huge amount
of computational resource
to do this type of analysis.
But as this technology
gets better,
this is the type of
data we're going to be
getting for every patient.
And it's not going
to simply be do
you have the mutation as a
binary variable, yes or no,
but is that mutation what we
call an early truncal mutation?
Is it present in all cells
or is present in just some?
This is an interesting
patient where we have
four tumors that we sequenced.
And this is how the
cBioPortal shows that.
And you can see for
these four genes,
these four mutations were
found in all four tumors.
But you could see the ERBB2
mutation was just in tumor one.
This PIK3CA mutation was
just in two and four.
We actually have drugs
against both of these targets.
The EGFR mutation was
only in tumor three.
The P10 only in tumor two.
So these are all
druggable mutations,
but they're not in
every single tumor cell.
And so this is an additional
level of complexity
that is going to
make this difficult.
And is really going to
require to eventually use
combinations of these inhibitors
to really see maximal effect.
So I'm just going
to leave it there
and just acknowledge
a number of people.
I really want to acknowledge
Gopa Iyer, a very talented-- he
was initially a postdoc fellow,
now junior faculty member who
was in my lab and
really started with me
this extraordinary
responder initiative.
The center I run, which is the
Kravis Center for Molecular
Oncology at Sloan
Kettering, I've
got three associate directors.
One, Mike Berger, who developed
this impact assay and really
deserves a lot of
credit for that.
Another, Agnes Viale, who runs
our operational sequencing
core.
And then Barry Taylor,
who we actually
recruited back from
UCSF just recently
to head what we call
computational oncology.
And this is really a new
field that didn't exist
before the last couple years.
And so what's
computational oncology?
These are people who use
computational tools to answer
clinical and biologic questions.
So we now have a whole
group of scientists
that that's what they're
going to be identified as,
as computational biologists
or computational oncologists.
And then just note
several other people.
Marc Ladanyi, who runs our
clinical sequencing lab
with Maria Arcila.
Dave Hyman, who runs a lot of
these basket studies with me,
and Jose Baselga, who's
our physician in chief,
and has really provided
a lot of leadership
to get this sequencing
effort up and running.
So thanks again
for the invitation.
Happy to answer any questions,
either now or formally later.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You showed a slide
where one person had you
said, 20 some mutations
in the prostate.
DAVID B. SOLIT: Yes.
This is--
AUDIENCE: And then you had a
previous slide further back
where you did a single tumor.
And you had 19,000
somatic mutations.
DAVID B. SOLIT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And from
what I read actually,
that's more the common
case versus the cancer
that you have very
few mutations.
The common case is that
you have tens of thousands
of mutations in a single tumor.
DAVID B. SOLIT: So let
me just clarify this
as an issue maybe
I wasn't clear on,
which is really differences
in the denominator.
So this assay that
I'm showing you here,
this was an assay of
just 341 cancer genes.
So this was our capture
based approach where we just
pull down parts of the genome.
And when we do that, the
scale's obviously different
because we're only sequencing
a small part of the genome.
We're sequencing the
part of the genome
with all the known
cancer genes in it,
but it's a very small
fraction of the total genome.
And so this is a lot of
mutations for sequencing
just that small part.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVID B. SOLIT:
The 19,000 referred
to sequencing the entire genome.
AUDIENCE: Right.
DAVID B. SOLIT: And
within that 19,000,
that patient probably had
about 140 coding mutations.
And if you actually
just ran IMPACT,
you probably only would have
found about eight or nine
mutations.
So it's really a difference
of what fraction of the genome
are we sequencing?
Those numbers are going to
be very different, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So maybe the premise
of my question is wrong.
But my question was if
you've got so many--
you kind of boiled it down
to a much smaller number--
but if you've got 19,000 somatic
mutations, how many, if you
were to look at so-called
normal cells in a normal person,
a typical assay, how
many mutations would you
find in normal cells?
DAVID B. SOLIT: So
the normal cells
have no mutations by
definition, because we're
using that as the reference
for each individual patient.
So there is the normal
coding sequence,
which is really created by an
amalgamation of many people.
And then there are variations
from individual to individual.
So because there's these
polymorphisms, or differences
in the genome
between individuals,
we actually don't want to
use this reference sequence
for the actual calling of
a mutation that's somatic.
We want to actually compare
this individual patient's
normal to this tumor
and actually then
digitally subtract it.
If you don't do
that, you'll end up
with thousands of
additional polymorphisms
between any individual
and actually
the reference sequence.
Now when we sequence the normal,
we don't sequence one cell.
We sequence what is DNA
extracted out of thousands
or tens of thousands of cells.
And so if you actually sequenced
just one individual cell,
you took hundreds of
them, you might even
see some mutations
that are slightly
different from this
cell to that cell.
But we don't pick it
up with this approach
because we're averaging that
out and then that detail's lost.
AUDIENCE: But it's radically
different in a cancer tumor,
right?
DAVID B. SOLIT:
But you know, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So a cancer
tumor, radically more.
DAVID B. SOLIT:
Dramatically higher, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So how
do you explain that
on a fundamental biological when
you're looking at first causes?
You would think,
for example, or I
would think-- just
kind of a lay person--
that if you imagine
that cancer is caused
by some initial
somatic mutation,
why does that single mutation
not dominate and survive
throughout the cancer?
So why do you have
tens of thousands?
This is a real mystery.
And it seems like a real
problem to this approach.
Because if you've got
tens of thousands--
and some places I've read
they say hundreds of thousands
of mutations in a single tumor--
DAVID B. SOLIT: Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: Then how?
DAVID B. SOLIT: So we actually
have a lot of sense for this
now with the Tumor Cancer
Genome Atlas that's been done.
There's very well
characterized whole exome data.
So not a lot of
whole genome data,
but whole exome data, showing
that, for example in melanomas,
it's not uncommon to have
3,000 or so exomic mutations.
And that's the tumor that has
the highest mutation rate.
There are many pediatric
cancers-- lymphomas
and leukemias-- that have an
exceedingly low mutation rate.
And some of it has to do with
the pathogenesis of the cancer.
So what was the
toxin that caused it?
So ultraviolet light is what's
causing these melanomas.
And actually many
of the mutations
are ones that are caused by
ultraviolet light induced
changes.
Whereas in lung
cancers, which is also
another hypermutated tumor,
the mutation spectrum
is a different type
of amino base pair
change than what you see in a
ultraviolet induced melanoma.
So many of these are passengers.
How many are actually
drivers, which
make the difference between
a driver and a passenger
is a driver really is
having a functional
effect in driving the
cancer pathogenesis,
we really don't
know in large part.
The presumption is the
vast majority of them
are passengers, they're
not doing anything.
But why are they there?
They're there
because there's just
a stochastic randomness to
where these mutations occur
in some ways.
And unless you hit on
something that actually
is presenting a
survival advantage,
it doesn't really matter.
So these mutations are
accumulating in a stem cell,
and what happens is you
get an early hit which
maybe makes a cell
proliferate a little bit more
quickly than normal.
So that cell starts to
replace the average population
of the normal cells.
But then in that, you get
a lot of random mutations
that are not doing anything.
But then eventually in
one of those cells that's
now built up more of
those random changes
you get a second hit.
And then it accumulates.
And then eventually
you can get a mutation
in a gene like MLH1 and MSH2,
and these genes actually
are important for
the DNA replication.
So once you get one of these
DNA repair deficient mutations,
there's just going to
be a huge number of now
additional mutations
that are caused
because these the
fidelity of DNA repair
or DNA reproduction is very low.
And so that's part of it.
I can't answer your
question completely.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It sounds
like eventually this
is going to go towards
if you have cancer,
you'll get a screening
upfront and figure out
what genomic
alterations you have
and you can match
them with a drug.
Do you think the
rate limiting factor
on that will be technology
or insurance or physician
adoption?
Which one of those is
the biggest hurdle?
DAVID B. SOLIT: So until this
past year, it was technology.
So even if you had
unlimited amounts of money,
you simply couldn't do this.
It would take a team of
dozens months or years
to do an individual genome.
And that's just not feasible.
But now my lab can do
a whole genome sequence
on any individual
for less than $10,000
if we spend X amount of
time to do the analysis.
So it's getting quicker and
it'll be turnkey more and more.
So as the informatic tools,
the algorithms get better,
they're more automated.
We actually are limited
by computational power
at Sloan Kettering.
You guys could laugh.
We have 1.5 petabytes of
memory and that's all we got.
And we've got a cluster
with this many processors.
And our thing is
some of the analysis
is waiting to get
on to the cluster.
We just don't have enough
computational power
to be doing more than we can.
And we spent $2.5
million last year
alone on computational
resources,
and that's a lot of money
for a nonprofit hospital
to be paying.
So right now, technology
is still limiting.
But that clearly is
going to go away.
The other problem
is doctor adoption.
I think even if the
technology becomes completely
turnkey and inexpensive, and
even if the insurance companies
start paying for some
degree-- and they're not
going to pay for whole
genome right away.
What they're going to do is
pay for some number of genes
and then as the cost
goes down, they'll
pay for more and more genes.
And then maybe
eventually it's cheaper
to just do the whole
genome in everyone.
But the other
downside of this is
doing this type of
sequencing somewhat
opens up a Pandora's box.
And that's because we all have
probably 10 to 20, if not more,
polymorphisms in our
normal cells that
put us at risk for something.
And it's not
something that we all
want to worry about
for our entire life.
So just to give you a
quick scenario here,
we run our genetic test here
for a patient with cancer
and the patient's cured.
One of the genes in our
assay is called PARK2.
And this is a gene that's
important for cancer.
It's a tumor suppressor.
It's a gene that was shown to be
a tumor suppressor in a paper I
published with a colleague
of mine, Tim Chan,
just a few years ago.
But the reason that the
gene is called PARK2
is because it's found
in the germ line,
so in the normal cells,
of patients who have early
onset Parkinson's disease.
And so imagine the scenario
of a patient coming in,
they get sequenced, we use the
sequencing data to tell them
how best to treat their cancer.
And then the oncologist
says, oh by the way,
you have a germ line
mutation of PARK2
and you have an 80% chance of
getting Parkinson's disease
by the age of 50, and we have
nothing we can do about that.
So did you want to
know that information?
And as we find more and more
of those susceptibility genes,
ones that maybe are less
penetrant, meaning they're
less of a phenotype
or less dominant,
we're all going to
have some of these.
And is this going to create
so much anxiety in all of us
that some people
are going to have
a hard time dealing with that?
So there is really a huge
amount of worry and concern
in the community as
we're doing this testing
to make sure that when
we look at the germ line
data in particular, that we're
very careful in how we counsel
the patients as to
what this means,
and that we don't return a lot
of information that is this
is a change in your germ line in
a gene that could be important
but we don't know what it means.
And then patients are
worrying about it.
So that's going to slow
physician adoption of this
a little bit.
But eventually, I think
all of us in the field
think eventually 10 years
down the line, 15 years down
the line, you're just going
to come in and in a day,
here's your tumor sequence.
And then we're going to match
you up to certain therapies
based upon that.
But getting there
is going to require
some significant
technologic improvements.
Definitely better
computational algorithms
for the analysis,
better databases
of what all these mutations
mean, not just somatically
but also in the germ line
alterations, and then also
better biologic
understanding of what
they mean so we
can counsel people
that they don't worry about
things that are not important.
And then probably even
new laws, because if you
tell that patient that they
have that PARK2 mutation, maybe
they can't get life
insurance, they
can't get health insurance.
Their family may have
the same mutation
and maybe can't get health
insurance or life insurance.
So this test is maybe
not just affecting you,
it's affecting your
family members.
So there's a little ways
to go until we sort out
all those issues.
AUDIENCE: When you
identified the mutations
and the responders,
do you also sequence
the genomes of the
people that don't
respond to confirm that they
don't have that mutation?
DAVID B. SOLIT: So for the
paper we published in "Science"
on that Everolimus trial--
I didn't show it here--
we unfortunately
didn't have tumor
for every patient
from the study.
But we did go back and
sequence a host of patients
from the study.
And what we found that
even the patients who
had minor responses
to Everolimus,
they also had a TSE1 mutation.
But what we found is that
the co-mutation pattern
for those patients
was different.
So this patient who had
the extraordinary response
had an NF2 mutation
with the TSE1.
And both of those,
we think, cooperate
to make that patient
exquisitely dependant
upon the target of that drug.
Other patients had a TSE1
mutation with other mutations
that we think diminish
addiction to that target,
but maybe a combination
would be helpful.
I think the learning experience
from that was going back,
we realized we didn't
have tumor from everyone.
So I think now we're trying to
do a much better job of making
sure that when we
run these studies,
we collect these tumors and
have the material available
for these type of
retrospective studies.
But actually some of the
extraordinary responders
initiatives are not
going to even be needed.
Because if we have the
mutation data perspectively,
it just becomes very
obvious sometimes why
somebody responded.
Well, they had the
right mutation.
And so the key is again getting
the tissue for study later on.
And it's a challenge.
I'm actually minimizing how
big of a challenge it is.
It's not necessarily just good
enough to have a piece of tumor
from five years ago
from the patient.
If they've had 10
therapies along the way,
the tumor may have changed
significantly during that time
and it's beyond what we're able
to do for every clinical trial,
to get a new piece of tumor
from every patient right
before they go on the therapy.
Because that's
invasive, it's costly.
And so we work with what
we have the best we can,
and it's not always perfect.
Well, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]